recently we announced that we were doing
death of the justice league and justice
league 75 coming out in april well the
thing that's spinning out of that is our
big blockbuster event of the summer
dark crisis dark crisis number one
starts in june
and really to me it's a story about all
these things that we love of the dcu
it's about the generational stuff it's
about the sidekicks it's about the
legacy of dcu
and i really wanted to show a crisis of
event from new different perspectives
we're going to be showcasing
all these new heroes and them having to
deal with the crisis for the first time
before dark rice number one starts in
june we have two one-shot specials that
will be bridging between justice league
75
and with dark prices number one first
there will be the dark crisis zero which
will be coming out on free comeback day
it's me and jim chung and we are telling
a story about the justice league and
showing why the best league matters and
why the justice league is great you know
why it is such an important part of the
dcu and then how people are dealing with
it like what happens after things gone
after they lose
and then we were doing a justice league
road to dark crisis one side special and
it's going to be showcasing what is
going on in this new world without
justice league with justice like 75 we
had this great cover by daniel simpier
and i've wanted to work with daniel for
a really long time but he's actually
going to be the artist on the series and
the art that he is doing is amazing the
stuff that we've seen on issue 1 is so
cool is so epic and big and really
showcases some of the best parts of the
dcu and it showcases this great
look at what this event is going to be
in just 675 when the justice league lose
all of these new heroes they have to
decide whether or not they're gonna be
able to step out of the shadows of the
previous justice league and rise up and
try to save earth zero and try to save
the multiverse it's been really fun to
see how different characters react to a
crisis how they get to react to this
loss that justice league has then which
ones are able to really embrace it and
become a better hero
this event is going to be a very fun
different event for dcu and is not going
to be what you'd expect
[Music]
you